it seems like a novelty a robotic diving
system that looks like an adorable
Transformer but ocean 1K is able to go
to depths that would kill a human diver
and it can handle delicate objects
without breaking them so the idea was to
build a robot that can imitate the human
shape so that it can be your avatar as
diver this Avatar mode is made possible
through a haptic system which allows The
Operators to literally feel what the
robot touches it is like if your hand is
inside the computer I mean I have to say
you're very good wired spoke with
Professor usuma kativ to understand how
he and his team designed built and
tested the robotic diver
foreign
a remotely operated vehicle in this case
an underwater ROV is Tethered to a ship
and controlled by an operator ocean 1K
was designed with archeology in mind we
wanted to design lightweight arms to
interact with Scientists we wanted them
also to be safe for their interaction
with the environment the challenge is
how can you do that the team tackled
three main design challenges by manual
manipulation haptic feedback
and buoyancy
the first challenge handling delicate
objects underwater started here with the
hands so we decided to go for a design
that uses under actuation it was very
efficient but three fingers was not
adapted to take all kind of different
objects that we wanted this hand has the
same concept but it has now four fingers
different material that is better for
sticking to objects underwater I mean
objects underwater are very slippery and
again here with one actuation you are
closing the hand it turns out that for
the first design we didn't have
actuation for the head ocean 1K can
track the motion of your hands can look
left and right up and down if you are
moving in a wide simulated environment
underwater or wherever you have
difficulty doing fine manipulation
without the depth information so the
stereo allows you to really feel like
you see exactly where your hand is with
respect to the world these classes
allowed researchers to see underwater in
3D all what you have to do is to take
these glasses and place the glasses and
now you can see in stereo
so we have a visual interface but also
you need to do and to connect and feel
and that is the haptic interface the
haptic interface allows operators to
feel what the robot is doing I always
say haptics is the most difficult thing
to explain we are using the sensors of
the robot that detect the forces and the
movement so if you have an object you're
pushing you're going to feel the
movement and the forces what we do is we
resolve them and send them to the top
through the computer algorithm and then
we reproduce them on the side of the
haptic the haptic device is essentially
a robot that is instead of acting on the
environment is acting on your hands and
it is reproducing the same forces that
are felt on the robot the tactile
information is being displayed by six
Motors on the haptic device I would like
to invite you to come and try it and so
I'm just moving it around it is like
kind of vibrating every time it falls
into like a hole so anything you can
model mathematically you can display
haptically is there any delay time like
yeah you guys are on the boat very very
good question it's not like tele
operation Loop the robot autonomous
system the haptic interface autonomous
system each of them uses a proxy and
they are just communicating what is
needed in terms of information
ocean 1K the team's latest ROV was
designed to go a thousand meters
underwater but the deeper you dive the
more pressure is exerted in order to
maintain the shape of their diver while
maintaining its ability to float the
team developed two novel Solutions
rovs are designed with metal we couldn't
do that we couldn't build a robot with
like thick cylinders and heavy
structures so you're going to use foam
it is essentially designed to make the
robot float up to 200 meters now imagine
we want to take this to 1000 meters the
pressure over it is going to be huge so
the only way you can do that is by
increasing the density and if you
increase the density then you are going
to have more weight more weight means
you need more volume and you end up with
the huge elephant size robot fortunately
material technology developed it's
called syntactic foam built with Hollow
microspheres like a glass and when they
touch each other they are going to
resist because because very strong and
very light Hollow the pressure
underwater at Great depths also meant
sensitive Electronics needed to be
protected so they developed this system
so the arm actually is completely filled
with oil and this oil is under a
pressure coming from outside through a
compensator now inside the arms you have
the same pressure as outside the arms
and then your safe oil field
structures is very important and Big
Challenge and believe me we didn't know
if it will succeed
the team tested their first prototype on
the Shipwreck La loon in 2016. between
2021 and 2022 they Dove on several sites
throughout the Mediterranean maneuvering
anywhere close to a shipwreck is very
dangerous 500 meters is not a place
where anyone can go and rescue the robot
we went to Aleria we brought a vase from
the Roman time that was on the cargo we
went with the camera inside the crispy
we were able to find some very
interesting biology structures that are
built by Iron eating bacteria the
biologist was surprised also to see that
these are usually found more in the
Atlantic in oceans not in the
Mediterranean but a delay from September
to February meant that the ROV set idle
for months ocean 1K didn't like it at
all one of the arms was really
complaining that to fix the connector
you had to disassemble the whole robot
because it's inside the shoulder with
underwater what are you hiding a lot of
things inside cylinders through
connectors like it's very dense inside
and it's all covered from outside or
protected I mean these are prototype of
the future robot so in the future the
actual robot that will be deployed will
have better integration of component
placement of component all these things
that you need to make your system easy
to to service
[Music]
so what's next for the future of ocean
1K operation underwater are going to be
critical for the future and I think not
only for archeology but imagine all the
structures the pipelines laying down the
fiber that we use for communication all
these structures requires maintenance
already we have a haptic device in the
space station developed by one of my
former PhD students transfer contact as
long as you have an internet connection
you can connect to the robot now imagine
we can control a robot from space all
the way underwater technically this is
feasible there are all kind of practical
issues to to to get to it thanks to the
conversions of Technologies from
computer technology to material to
maturity of the field of Robotics all
together that is finally helping
robotics to to to move forward
[Music]